欢迎收听有道保库AI播客节目，欢迎收听今天的深度播客节目。
今天我们要聊一个非常硬核，但又和当下每一个行业都息息相关的话题。
大家应该都有这种感觉，就是现在网上的AI大模型演示案例满天飞，看着都特别惊艳，好像无所不能。
但是呢，一旦你真的要把大模型搬进企业的生产环境里，尤其是向企业克服这种对准确率要求极高，
绝对不允许模型胡说八道生成虚假内容的场景。实际落地的翻车率其实是非常高的。
没错，这其实就是演示级产品和生产级产品之间的一道巨大红沟。
很多企业在尝试接入大模型的时候，最怕的就是模型产生幻觉。
你想象一下，一个车企的智能客服如果凭空给客户捏造了一个不存在的购车优惠，
或者把续航里程爆错了，这引发的客诉和公关危机是不可估量的。
所以今天我们要深度拆解的这份极具参考价值的技术报告就非常有代表性。
它完整纪录了一家车企客服系统，从早期的实验版本迭代升级到v2.1版本的全过程。
这不仅是一份系统升级日治，更像是一套教你怎么把大模型真正落地用起来的实战兵法。
对，这份报告干货实在太多了，现在整个行业都在热议。
大模型怎么落地才算稳定合规。
而这个车企客服v2.1版本可以说是给出了一个教科书级别的解决方案。
他们完成了一次架构层面脱胎换骨的转变，就是从早期那种把业务知识死死写在代码里的传统模式，
全面升级到了现在业界公认的检索增强生成架构，也就是我们常听到的RAG架构。
那么今天我们就按照苏格拉底式的提问方法层层剥开这套系统的外衣。
我们先探究事务的本质，也就是从第一性原理出发来剖析这场架构褪变。
首先我想问的是，如果一个老系统能跑得通，技术团队通常是不会轻易驱动底层架构的。
那么这个初代版本到底存在什么致命的缺陷？迫使他们必须进行这种伤惊动骨的重构呢？
如果我们用第一性原理来拆解，不管技术怎么变，企业客服系统的核心本质是什么？
其实就是8个字精准高效的解答疑问，而初代版本恰恰在这个本质问题上走入了死胡同。
初代版本最大的痛点，我们可以总结为知识偶和。
什么意思呢？
就是当时的开发团队把车企各个车型的售价、续航里程、配置参数，
这些千变万化的产品信息，以字典的格式直接硬编码，也就是固化在了Python代码里面。
把业务数据写在代码里，这听起来就像是把一本随时要更新的商品目录直接刻在了石碑上一样。
这在实际运营中肯定是个灾难吧。
形容得非常贴切，一旦产品线出现任何微调，哪怕只是某一款车型的脚垫价格变了10块钱，
业务人员自己是没法改的，必须由研发人员把代码翻出来，手动修改，
再重新走一遍完整的代码测试、发布和部署流程。
在现在这种业务飞速迭代的市场环境下，这种模式完全就是脱后腿。
而且，这种传统模式只能做最简单的自服串匹配。
用户要是换个说法提问，系统就傻眼了，完全无法精准识别用户的真实意图。
后期维护成本极高，智能化程度又严重不足。
所以，为了回到精准高效解答问题，这个第一性原理上，第一步就是要砸碎这块石碑。
也就是说，必须要让拥有一套完整，且可以灵活更新的知识库成为可能。
这就要求知识库和业务代码必须彻底解偶。
那么也如刚才提到的RAG架构，也就是减所增强生成架构。
具体是怎么实现这种解偶的呢？
RAG架构的核心逻辑，
其实就是实现职责拆分和分工协作。
你可以把它理解为，给大模型配了一个极其专业的资料是管理员。
减所模块就是这个管理员，
专职负责从外部的独立知识库里调取真实的文档资料。
而大模型呢，它不再依赖自己脑子里那些可能过时或者模糊的训练知识，去凭空捏造答案了。
它现在只做一件事，就是拿到管理员递过来的真实文档，去做语言的组织和逻辑的书里。
这种模式直接掐断了大模型湖边乱造的源头，大幅减少了虚假信息的深沉。
专业的人做专业的事，功能解偶本来就是软件工程设计的核心准则。
既然要把知识库从代码里剥离出来，变成一个独立的外置知识库，
我猜很多人第一反应，肯定是去买一套很昂贵、架构很复杂的传统数据库系统。
但是我看报告里说，团队并没有这么做，而是采用了一种非常清亮化的方案。
这是出于什么考量？
这恰恰是很多技术团队容易踩坑的地方，总觉得越复杂的工具越好。
但这份报告给出的主流优选方案是，用清亮化的markdown文件来存储业务知识。
markdown其实就是一种纯文本的排版格式。
它是目前技术文档和业务知识库最适配的载体。
为什么选它？因为清亮而且自带天然的标题层级结构。
比如一级标题写企业整体介绍。
二级标题写具体产品线。
三级标题写车型参数。
这种结构化的特性为后来我们要讲的文档分断和切片处理，提供了极大的便利。
而且更直观的好处是，markdown对飞技术人员太有好了。
运营人员不用去学写代码，甚至不用懂CQ语句。
用普通的文本编辑器就能直接修改内容。
改完之后，网指定目录一放，系统自动就加载生效了。
这等于是把更新知识库的权力直接交还给了业务线，
彻底砍掉了研发排期这个漫长的前置环节。
是的，不仅如此，这背后还隐藏着一个业界非常推崇的理念，叫做文档及代码。
因为markdown是纯文本文件，
所以可以直接揭入像git这样的代码版本管理工具进行管控。
你想象一下，如果运营人员不小心手抖，
把一辆二、三十万的车的价格少撬了一个零怎么办。
在过去的系统里，这就成了生产事故。
但现在有了版本管理，只要点一下鼠标，就能一键回管到历史正确版本。
这就让整个系统的可维护性和容错率实现了数倍的提升。
这确实是一个四两波千金的精妙设计。
外壳搭建好了，知识库也结偶了。
那么接下来，我们就要面对核心的硬核挑战了。
怎么从这个库里精准的把知识捞出来？
外界一直有一种认知误区。
觉得现在AI这么牛，只要接上大模型，再挂个项量数据库，
作语一匹配，什么检索问题都能迎刃而解。
但这份报告却实实在在地打脸了这种天真的想法。
他们并没有忙碌依赖纯项量检索，
而是搞了一个双引擎混合检索架构。
为什么项量检索这么聪明了，还不够用呢？
这个问题问到了大模型落地的深水区。
项量检索确实很聪明，它擅长理解寓意相思度。
比如用户在输入框问，摸抖三的售价是多少？
即使你的知识库文当里写的原话是。
摸抖三的定价标准，项量检索也能懂这两句话是一个意思，
从而精准匹配。
但是，项量检索有一个致命的短板，
那就是对于冷门专业数语，小众定制化名词的识别敏感度非常低。
能举个具体的例子吗？
在车企的实际客服场景里，这种短板是怎么暴露出来的？
报告里给了一个非常典型的采刊案例。
比如用户搜索一个专业定制名词叫OEM门。
如果你的项量知识库里刚好缺乏同类的语义特征，
或者底层的项量模型，在训练的时候根本没学过这个偏门的专业数语。
那么，项量检索在面对OEM门这三个字的时候，
又会完全抓瞎，导致根本检索不到对应的文档段落。
那这怎么解决？总不能让客服机器人跟客户说，我听不懂这个词吧？
所以这时候，古老但可靠的传统关键词检索算法就派上用场了。
团队引入了业界非常经典的BM25算法。
这个算法根本不管什么深层语义理解，
它就是个铁面无私的寄建功，
只通过词评、逆文档、频率这些数学规则，
去文档里死磕专业关键词的字面匹配，
把善长语义理解的项量检索和善长精准字面匹配的BM25相结合。
这就是双引擎混合检索，既能听懂大白话，又不会漏掉专业词。
报告里还通过大量实测给出了一个黄金权重配比，
项量检索占0.7，BM25占0.3。
0.7比0.3，这个比例非常有意思。
这也是基于真实业务场景推导出来的第一性原理吧？
因为在绝大多数情况下，用户的提问肯定是以自然语言为主的。
所以语义理解，拿大头占0.7。
而剩下的30%的精准匹配权重，其实是守住了底线。
直接决定了克服回答够不够专业，会不会遗漏关键信息。
听说上了这套混合架构后，文档召回率比单一模式提升了差不多30%，
这绝对是个质的飞跃。
没错，效果立干见影。
顺着这个检索架构，我们还要聊聊背后的技术选型逻辑。
现在市面上的主流分布式相量数据库多得是，功能一个比一个花少。
但你知道这份报告最后选了什么吗？
他们选了meta开源的一个清亮级框架，叫face。
这又是一个反直觉的选择。
很多团队一做大模型项目，就恨不得把全套最前沿的微服物架构，
最热门的分布式组建全搬进来，觉得这样才显得技术牛。
为什么这个团队反其道而行之，选了这么个极简的框架？
因为资深的架构师知道技术边界在哪里，盲目跟风大型组建。
在项目初期只会带来资源的严重浪费和沉重的运为负担。
你看车旗克服这个业务场景，核心知识库满打满算，
也就是产品介绍、企业信息这些文档。
切片之后，在相量库里的片段可能也就几十到几百个。
数据体量其实是非常小的，是配业务体量、清量化、够用极可。
这才是真正的工程落地思维。
Face在这种中小体量场景下简直如于得水。
它连独立的数据库服务都不用部署，直接在本地内存里跑，性能极高。
实测单次检索号是控制在240毫秒以内，这就是典型的极简高效。
不要为了杀机去买一把涂轮刀，适合的才是最好的。
你刚才提到了切片这个词，这其实是整个系统跑得快，跑得准的另一个隐藏工程。
把长篇大论的文档拆分开存进数据库里，这个动作叫文档预处理。
我了解到的传统做法非常简单粗暴，就是一刀切。
比如设定好每500个字符强制砍一刀，
但这份报告却极力推崇一种叫层次化文档切片的技术。
传统的那种固定长度切片，到底会切出什么毛病来？
固定长度切片就是不管三七二十一，闭着眼睛按字数切，
这会导致一个极其荒谬的后果，一份文档的逻辑结构被粗暴地斩断了。
比如，上一段切片的结尾刚好是个主语，
这款发动机下一段切片的开头是个位语，采用了最新技术。
大模型在读取这种残缺的碎片化内容时，
就像在看被减碎的报纸，极容易产生逻辑理解偏差，
回答准确率自然就崩了。
这其实违背了我们刚才说的，markdown天然具备标题层级的优势。
那层次化切片是怎么利用这个优势的？
层次化切片就是顺势而为，
它完全遵循文档天然的逻辑框架，
利用markdown的一级、二级标题，
在章节的自然边界完成初次拆分。
这样就能保证每一个拆分出来的单元，
都是一个完整、独立的业务逻辑模块。
在这个基础上，在用代码进行精细化的二次分割，
报告里测试出的最优切片长度依然是500字符，
但关键在于，他们设计了50字符的上下文重叠区域。
这个重叠区域就像是气砖的时候，
两块砖中间的那个咬合缝隙，
保证了段落之间的语异不会断层，是紧密连贯的，
而且设定在500个字符也是精心计算过的吧。
太短了信息零碎，大模型看不懂。
太长了，不仅浪费算力资源，
还会导致大模型抓不住重点，回答偏题。
解释得太到位了。
另外，层次化切片还有一个杀手剪，
就是它完整保留了文档原始的层级、原数据。
这意味着什么？
意味着大模型在生成回答的时候，
可以自带身份证，
它能明确告诉用户，
我这句回答不是瞎编的，
是引用自某某文档的某某章节。
这完美解决了AI落地中最让人头疼的知识溯源问题。
知识溯源太重要了，
这是建立人机信任的基石。
聊到这里，
我们已经从底层的知识库解偶混合检索，
一路聊到了数据切片处理。
可以说，给大模型输送弹药的整条拱一连都已经非常完美了。
那么最后负责上前线打仗的智能体Agent，
也就是这套系统的大脑。
在这个v2.1版本里，又做了哪些进化呢？
这里体现了系统优化的另一个高级思维，做简法。
在早期版本里，为了显得智能体很强大，
团队给它设计了双工具，多通道。
有的通道去读硬编码字典，
有的通道去调大模型，
结果呢？
在真实的客服场景里，
多元数据分散杂乱，
不仅维护起来极其痛苦，
而且经常发生两个通道给出的答案互相打架的情况。
更要命的是，
面对多工具、智能体自己也会陷入选择困难症。
不知道该用哪个，
这在生产环境里是绝对不允许的隐患。
这就又回到了第一性原理。
系统越复杂，越容易崩溃。
要提升稳定性，就必须收敛路径。
所以v2.1版本是大刀闊斧地砍掉了那些荣誉的通道，
只保留了一个核心入口。
对，彻底精减，只保留唯一的REC知识库检索工具。
用户不管问什么，智能体统一从同一个。
经过严格处理的共享知识池里拿答案。
这样一来，智能体根本不需要消耗算理。
去纠结选哪个工具。
它只需要专注做好一件事，
把用户的自然语言精准翻译成检索指令。
所有业务知识来源统一，
彻底杜绝了数据打架的情况。
这种由凡至简的架构收敛，
才是系统达到真正生产级可用标准的标志。
一路梳理下来，感觉真憨畅临离，
从底层逻辑到顶层设计，
这就是一次工业级的标准化重构。
不过，技术迭代是没有终点的。
就像报告，最后也规划了未来的眼睛路线。
站在行业的角度看，
接下来要想让这套系统的用户体验，
再上一个台阶，
这几项是可以立刻着手去做的高优先级优化。
报告里提出了三项直击痛点的短期规划，都非常落地。
第一项叫流逝输出，
简单来说，就是像真人打字一样，
字是一个一个蹦出来的，
这其实是个心理学设计。
你想想，
如果你问了个问题，
屏幕上只有一个圈，在那里一直转，
等个五六秒，你可能就不耐烦关掉了。
但如果是流逝输出，
实时看到系统在思考和生成，
这能极大缓解用户的等待焦虑，
这已经是现在优秀大模型产品的标配了。
确实,
让用户觉得对面的AI是活的，
而不是一个死板的机器。
那第二项呢？
第二项，
是赋予系统对话历史记忆能力，
现在的很多客服还是个惊鱼脑，
你上一句问了model3的价格，
下一句问，那他的续航呢？
他可能就不懂他是指谁了。
引入记忆机制后，
系统就能像专业顾问一样，
根据上下文进行多轮连贯的深度沟通。
第三项呢？
其实就是我们前面铺垫过的。
信息引用标注避还，
利用层次化切片保留的元数据，
在每次回答的末尾，
加上清晰的来源出处。
这对企业机商用太关键了，
方便员工和客户核验真伪，
是目前RAG架构的最佳实践。
这三项一旦落地，
这一副系统就不单单是回答得准了，
更是聊得好，让人幸福了。
看完这份详实的升级报告，
我们最大的感触是，
以此高规格的技术重构，
并不一定要去堆砌最昂贵的软硬件。
通过合理的架构解偶，
恰当的工具选行，
系统的可维护性能提升十倍以上，
这是一笔投资回报率极高的买卖。
没错，魔鬼都在细节里，
大模型在业务落地中，
从来都不是一件介入那么简单，
无论是产品经理还是架构师，
这份从v1到v2.1的实战经验，
都值得我们反复拒绝。
遵循第一性原理，
用工程化的思维，
去解决那些看似索粹，
但致命的问题，
才是让AI从玩具。
变成生产力的唯一途径。
总结得非常精闢，
非常感谢你今天带来的深度拆解，
也希望能给正在摸索大模型落地的。
听众朋友们带来切实的启发。
感谢各位收听本期播客，
我们下期节目再见。